[Music]
hey guys game night at my house tonight
coming I have to go to the gym hey dude
great job in that project it was so good
why girl what's with your lunch I have
to eat a certain amount of macros with
every meal
so there's macronutrients and
micronutrients micronutrients are like
your vitamins in your mint hey George
no here we go guys just a few more miles
I eat a certain amount of each one with
every meal so I need you know like 18
grams of protein and so like that's why
I have the chicken and then I need
vegetables with every meal not hang out
I'm Saturday let's go to a gym all day
let's have a lazy weekend yeah with
Netflix and pizza no I think we should
go on a hike we need to get outside and
move our bodies burn some calories sweat
a little bit here we go guys a couple
more sets squeeze those ABS chest Denise
oh god it hurts so much you got it nice
work my just embrace the paint Oh Oh
we'll be done soon I don't know if I can
do any more you guys are doing great
work